[Musik]
440 fehlstunden der isa meine damen und
herren
luca ist natürlich wieder am start ich
habe der lupo gesagt sie sollen mir auf
twitter mit dem hashtag lehrer luca ihre
zeugnisse posten und das dir getan das
hier ist das erste zeugnis ab dass wir
heute reagieren das ist von der navi duo
anna ist geboren am 8 januar 2002 das
ist jetzt weg
[Musik]
zwischen 15 und 30 jahren sind gute
noten luana ich will ein bisschen mehr
lernen das ist das nächste zeugen das
was wir uns heute anschauen einem sieht
ein bisschen anders aus weil das die
noten sind echt verhältnismäßig sehr
sehr sehr sehr gut leider wurde nahmen
et cetera hier alles komplett nicht dazu
geschrieben also lieber schüler der mir
dieses hier geschickt hat sehr gut
weiter so und du wirst neuer präsident
ein paar sekunden später acht tage der
hat mir auch noch sein zeugnis von dem
jahr zuvor geschickt ausreichend
ausreichend ausreichend mangelhaft nicht
erteilt mangel hat man gesagt
ausreichend mangelhaft mangelhaft machen
was kannst du hast nicht heftig
verbessert alter glück und genau so war
es bei mir auch nur andersrum
also ich war erst richtig guten schul-
und dann würde ich immer schlechter das
hier ist das zeugnis von der lieben
hanna die hanna ist geboren am 10
oktober 2001 also das ist ihr zeugnis wo
sie 14 15 jahre alt war und ist sport
kann sich noch ein bisschen dich
verbessern musst du hast in jedem fall
eins bleibt wahrscheinlich einfach nicht
mehr so viel zeit für sport allgemein
muss ich mal eben sagen das ich
natürlich nicht wenn jetzt jemand
irgendwie ne 4 und eine 5 und so erzeugt
es hat wenn ich dann halt sage hey
lernen mal ein bisschen mehr dann ist
natürlich nicht negativ gemeint ihr
solltet mich alle mittlerweile so weit
kennen dass ihr wisst das ist alles hier
nur humor und satire sarkasmus et cetera
ist die sache ist ja auch zeugnisnoten
spiegeln ja auch nicht intelligenz eine
person wieder sondern notwendig weil ich
war sehr weil ich die allerbeste in der
schule habe ich irgendwie mit 2
war auf jeden fall nicht so gut diese
scheichs kamera ihr dreht sich die ganze
zeit schulnoten sagen einfach nur aus
wer am meisten gelernt hat wir haben
disziplinierteste nicht gesagt hey hier
raus fußball spielen sondern ich setz
mich ein schreibtisch und du hast meine
noten bis ihr zeugnis von der allee nahe
sehr interessanter name und das zeugnis
ist
sie hat in jedem fach eine 3 also
komplett ist durchschnitt zeugnis außer
in textilgestaltung einer einst allein
geschmort designer von zukunft kommen
wir nun allerdings zudem glaube ich
wirklich schlechtesten zeugnis was mir
zugeschickt wurde und zwar dass hier von
der felina sind einfach nur vieren und
fünfen auf dem zeugnis und sie wurde
auch nicht in die nächste klasse
versetzt also für ihn dass wir auf jeden
fall leid du müsstest dich wirklich in
allen fächern verbessern außer verhalten
da hast du tatsächlich eine 2 ich habe
jetzt so richtig vorstellen was die
berliner für eine schülerin ist eine
ganz ganz ganz ganz liebe die aber
wahrscheinlich auch noch nebenbei dann
irgendwie streitschlichter ist und noch
tanzt und noch soziale sachen macht und
für die schule keine zeit mehr hat so
dass du willst einfach dumm spart love
you felina liebe zimmer hatten wir hier
ein foto geschickt von zwei ihrer
zeugnisse und zwar auf der rechten seite
ein zeugnis von der achten klasse im
zweiten halbjahr da war sie noch relativ
vernünftig in der schule hatte seinen
durchschnitt zeigt das doch dann in der
nächsten klasse ein halbes jahr später
hat sie komplett reingeschüttet
das kann ich nachvollziehen bei mir war
es ja auch so dass ich wirklich bissig
youtube gemacht habe war ich unfassbar
gut in der schule also halt gut ich
hatte so ein schnitt von 17 18 so und
das habe ich halt mit youtube angefangen
und hatte halt mehr und mehr zeit in
youtube investiert und in videos
aufnehmen zocken et cetera und dann halt
noch mit fußball nebenher da war ich
wirklich von 17 bin ich dann auf 33
runter oder noch schlecht das war echt
ne scheiße waren wir allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten zeugnis kommen
justin harris ist ein ja auch relativ
schlecht eigentlich also das find ich
würde auch dir empfehlen sich
tatsächlich in jedem fall grundsätzlich
wie stark zu verbessern das hier ist
auch eine echt sie beschissenes zeugnis
die ganze luca besteht nur aus holz
köpfen der leute ich hoffe ihr wisst das
ist natürlich alles nur spaß ist die
meisten leute die mir das karriere- und
sagen das hier geschickt da meine noch
selber guck mal wie schlecht nicht da
war und so weiter und so fort
sie haben es auch gern mit humor
genommen weil dort stehen bei mir war es
wirklich früher auch so dass ich mich in
not und total rein versetzt habe ich
habe mich in noten rein versetzt ich
habe mir immer voll gedanken gemacht
wenn ich irgendwie der schule mal eine
vier hat oder so aber letztendlich im
nachhinein alter das sind einfach nur
noten wenn in einer sache gut drin seit
geben alle leute den scheiß darauf ob
ihr im kunsthandel oder ein allerdings
habe tatsächlich auch in unserer
community einige leute die diszipliniert
am lernen sind hier beispielsweise fast
jede note eins auf dem zeugnis ich finde
es interessant wie zeugnisse sage ich
mal variieren also das design und
die noten sage ich mal beschrieben
werden die zeugnisse bekommen werden
noten in flüssen angezeigt das ist eine
2 beispielsweise ein plus mit einem
pfeil nach oben die zum beispiel ist es
eher ein zeugnis was ich auch damals auf
dem gymnasium hatte das ist die klasse
7c es ist ein komplettes standards
zeugnis ist glaube ich einen schnitt von
3,2 3,3 oder so aber dann beispielsweise
bei dem zeugnis von dem anbieter hier
aus der achten klasse werden die noten
nicht mehr ausgeschrieben was steht da
nicht sehr gut oder ausreichen sondern
da stehen dann denke ich die zahlen
warum habe ich überhaupt die brille auf
alltag
ich wollte eigentlich rabatte machen mit
dem nächsten zeugnis dann hab ich mir
deine fehlstunden angeschaut 400 sich
fehlstunden digger du hast jetzt mehr
nicht indischen plätze darüber ist dass
sie zum beispiel dass im zeugnis was wir
auch in der oberstufe hatten auf meinem
gymnasium einem das sagt exakt genauso
aus es war wirklich exakt genauso haus
alltag vielleicht war auch meine schule
aber sowas hier wieder so das zeugnis
von der alice ja das sieht halt wirklich
eins zu eins so aus wie so ein zeugnis
aus der grundschule fündig das ist eine
achte klasse okay ich meine dass das war
also das typische zeug das ich früher
hatte sie als objekt schon ziemlich
scheiße aus das sollten wir von der
laura es ist wirklich wieder ein
komplettes durchschnitt zeugnis aus
altach das ist vierte klasse gewesen
weil ich dachte gerade schon so hey
warum wird deutschland noch einmal
aufgeteilt in sprachgebrauch lesen und
rechtschreiben aber das ist natürlich
ein grundschulzeugnis rechtschreiben hat
sie eine fünf lernen schreiben verdammt
ich hoffe dass jetzt das zeuge das von
kevin
er hat ja in die noten von kevin sony
sowie allerbesten arbeitsverhalten
entspricht den erwartungen mit
einschränkungen sozialverhalten
entspricht nicht den erwartungen und
bemerkungen der abschlusses gefährte
lamarche die lager hat das zeugnis hier
und ja auch in jedem fach gar nicht mal
so gut außer musik da ist nur zwei da
finde ich sieht man halt immer was mit
den schülern hingehen und wenn du
wirklich in musik mit zwei hast aber in
allen anderen fächern er drei bis vier
bis fünf dann wüsstest wir wissen
ich werde neue elvis presley das hier
ist jetzt wieder so ein komplett anderes
zeugnis
da stehen einfach die noten so an
schriftlich oder diese handschriftlichen
front aufgestellten teilnahme an
folgenden arbeitsgemeinschaften
kristalle züchten kristalle züchten bei
anderen steht irgendwie so edv workshop
und so war ihm steht einfach christel
zwischen das hier ist das vorletzte zeug
das was ich mir heute rausgesucht habe
ich weiß nicht wie die person heißt weil
er den kompletten namen zensiert hat ms
s klasse 8a und in noten sind schlecht
das arbeitsverhalten entspricht nicht
den erfahrungen er zeigt nicht die
nötige arbeitsbereitschaft und arbeitet
oft nichts mitte sie erledigen sie ist
eine sie sorry die erledigt aufgaben und
aufträge nicht zuverlässig beim
sozialverhalten steht das
sozialverhalten entspricht den
erwartungen mit einschränkungen sie hält
sich nicht an regeln und vereinbarungen
und ist nicht bereit das eigene
verhalten zu essen
sie wurde auch nicht versetzt direkt
solche bisschen verhalten ändern und das
jetzt das letzte zeugnis von der lieben
carla
ist auch ein relativ normales zeugen
wenn ich mich jetzt die noten anschaue
ist alles querbeet mit dabei ist es nur
eins mit dabei ist eine fünf mit dabei
und ok hier steht auch dass sie fast
auch nicht gefährdet wie heute nicht
versetzt wird eine brille häufig
vollidiot wir zum abschluss nochmal
ihren text durch und zwar steht hier
klarer ist eine aufgeweckte und
fröhliche schülerin ja das wäre das
gegenteil von aufgeweckt eine schlafende
schülerinnen die durch einwandfreies
betragen lehrkräften gegenüber gefällt
in der klassengemeinschaft ist sie
beliebt ihr amt als klassensprecherin
übt sie engagiert aus mit interesse
folgten sieben unterrichts gespräch dass
sie häufig auch mit treffenden beiträgen
bereichert schriftlich arbeiten fertig
klarer oftmals nicht termingerecht und
vollständig an der häuslicher fleiß
stellten nicht zufrieden clara könnt ihr
auch weißt du überhaupt klar
also du könntest auch noch mal so ein
bisschen engagierter sein aber du bist
ja auch schon klassensprecherin also
vielleicht hast du auch ein bisschen zu
viel zu tun
meine damen und herren an der stelle
würde ich aber auch das heutige video
jetzt beenden ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
zuschauer von euch aus der luke schuhe
haben mir auch twitter unter dem hashtag
lehrer luca ihr zeugnis gepostet dafür
wollte ich mich auf jeden fall bei euch
bedanken
ich möchte wirklich in diesem video hier
keinen irgendwie fertig machen oder
sagen hey du hast eine fünfte bist ein
schlechter werden noten sagen nichts
über den charakter eines menschen aus
beziehungsweise über die intelligenz
meiner meinung nach eher schreibe ich
mir mal bitte unten die kommentare was
einerseits euer bester schnitt war
bisher offen ist und was euer
schlechtesten schnitt war bei mir war es
glaube ich 15 3,3 oder irgendwie so
bewertet das video gern mit einem daumen
hoch wenn ich noch mal auf zeugnisse von
euch reagieren soll und sonst kommt
jetzt das auto
[Musik]